[Music]
tonight is the return of America's Got
Talent and I visited Simon Cowell at
home in Beverly Hills to find out what
surprises are in store this time
[Applause]
I did leave by the way that was her
first ago uh no no she can't be doing
that
I wish she's like 11 she's got a real
shot
[Music]
[Applause]
when bombarded with ventriloquist's pole
sitters and fire spinners it's the
audience helping Simon get a read you've
got about two or three thousand people
behind you and it's the weirdest thing
when somebody's good there is a
different kind of energy you feel
immediately behind you that was amazing
and when it's really good the place goes
crazy the funny thing is they can spot
the good ones as well
instantly no way tonight we'll see how
those fans react to the piano playing
chicken
but if there ever is a rejection new
hoes Tyra Banks now mom to 16 month old
York is there to dry the tears
especially if a child's get to know
let's just give them the mama hug and
say it's gonna be okay
I want to be held by Tyra how different
is it working together on a GT than when
you guys were starting out as bottles
together now we talk about different
things in fact way back when you know
then we talked about lashes and eye
shadow colors and now it's about like
schools and how do you do this when you
travel here and there so it's cute
[Music]
you